every uh uh great Empire is going to
have some some sort of a secret
intelligence organization us has the CIA
Britain had the Mi has the MI6 Israel
mad Iran had savak but here's the here's
the interesting thing couple of the
people that betrayed your your father
one of them was uh uh uh Hussein fardus
Hussein fardus was one of the Deputy
directors of savak for 10 years and you
know your your grandfather this is the
St your your your your grandfather I
believe was sending your father to
France to go get educated and to
accompany him he paid for fardus to go
with him to France I believe if I'm not
mistaken so they went there together
fardus comes back I think they were in
uh the Ros School in yes so so then they
come back so meaning imagine what this
family is doing to you and you end up
being the one that betrays him and then
he goes from being a deputy director for
Saka and everybody's like how come they
never killed him he becomes a leader of
savam savam is like similar of savak but
fori and then later on when you when you
kind of do a little bit more digging and
you you hear stories about him and
general
abos that there was a you know
relationship there between the two of
them you know now some people have
speculated that's how Ki was able to get
Intel from him because he promised the
information wasn't going to be leaked to
the public that you're maybe like a
jayed g Hoover type you're gay and that
was kind of something that was kept now
again this isn't public information you
know I I'm I'm doing my research and
talk to a lot of different people to see
who's saying this stuff we also got a
couple calls from people we spoke to
Iran that said these things there was
betrayal and those same people from saak
some of them ended up helping saan but
secret intelligence is going to be
around for a while no matter how big the
organization is and no one's ever going
to no one looks at CIA says what a great
organization MI6 what a great
organization your job as somebody being
part of that intelligence is you're
going to get criticized a lot so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right
here